now I said five minutes ago that I was
gonna ask you a very similar set of
questions for GPS that I did with APs
don't you have a look at what my next
question was for the a piece do you
remember question to once you have a
look at it what did I ask
yep so I wanted to say just prove it
use the test we will use the test in a
minute but the reason why I use the test
with the show is it ain't paid you don't
talk to the second question which was
tell me when does that kick- when does
it hit negative okay now I hope it's
gonna become clear in a very brief
moment enough this table isn't on then I
cannot ask this question for GP well I
mean I can but it's a big meaningless
really okay so let me try to illustrate
for you why again I'm going to do it as
a compare contrast okay
I'm going to think about ApS and then
I'm going to think about which romantic
alright now what I want you to get a
feeling for is how do you a peas and GPS
think of them kind of like kind of like
little objects little living objects
that behave in a certain way okay
just like when you think of functions
right you can think of linear functions
and parabolic functions functions sort
of acts in a kind of way you get a feel
for it right like we've come to the
point now where if I say x squared it's
actually hard to not think of the shape
of a parabola because you guys been
working with you so long now I want to
get this I'm actually going to give you
some pictures we're going to draw some
things together to try and give it get a
feel for how a piece of GPs behave based
on remember there are only two numbers
two numbers that define an AP or a GP
and those two numbers are either first
term in common difference or the first
term in the common ratio okay so if we
think about what's happening to each of
these first term
difference this first term ratio we will
get a sense of how the different kinds
of a peas in Cuba peas
like behave okay yes so this is my
reason why I couldn't ask the second
question that I asked before I can't ask
it of GPS and when we get to this last
row of this table probably before that
you'll see what's going on but wait the
last row you'll see why so what I want
to add a muck around with is that that
question was about so that positive
negative okay so I'm not interested in
like magnitude I'm just interested in is
something class or is it - okay so I'm
going to use two colors here I'm gonna
go watch how much shoes I'm gonna go
black and green okay I'm going to use
black for negative and green for
positive okay so let's think about the
simplest possible case if I have an AP
and the first term is positive and the
common difference is also positive okay
I know my table okay I'm starting to
fill it out from the Bly it looked a bit
backwards but you'll see why hopefully
what um if I have a first term it's
positive then I have a common difference
it's positive okay what will all of the
terms in the AP be in terms of sine they
will all be positive because you start
somewhere above zero and then you just
keep going up right you should keep
going up so in other words
personally I'm gonna say they're all
positive every single term is positive
and I draw a picture for this so if I
imagine an a progression as like a young
numbers and so on
all of them are positive I smell it
because my dot dot dot continues they're
all positive are you happy with that now
in the same way I could do the opposite
case right is instead I had a first term
that was negative and I also had a
common difference that was negative so
I'm imagining the terms progressing
along and they're all gonna be positive
right so they're all green
okay just trust me just write things
once we get off people raising it now if
I started a negative stop below ground
and I just start digging get even more
negative what will happen to all the
turns in terms of sign so another words
I've got the same kind of thing but well
maybe now just to put some other
language on this write to draw some
parallels this is a little bit like we
can you know we had quadratics trees
this is a bit like positive definite
everything any value you put in there
you put some term you kick some time and
they're all very positive and here you
pick some term any term you like
they'll all be negative is that okay now
let's think about that question I gave
you a question to with the APS right
what was on a the first term in terms of
society what was it but we worked out
very quickly by testing that the common
difference is negative remember that you
know what will happen these were our
picture stuff to get useful me okay what
happens is that there is a small number
of terms a finite number of terms in
fact there are positive okay but at some
point what was it the 13th of what it's
at the 14th turn it hits negative and
then it's negative forever right it
never recovers it's a little bit like
starting a bump around and then you
start deep because you're digging you
never turn around it's never going to
come back up become positive so
therefore my diagram is gonna look like
this you start positive and then you hit
negative now the reason why I've gone
this negative part so much bigger is
because this green pot is finite and the
black pot is infinite it never ends so
no matter how big this is like you could
start at a million and take a long time
to get to negative but once you get
there
this is always going to be like
disproportionately long in that it will
be infinite time longer actually
so therefore what are we getting here in
our picture it's positive right and then
it becomes how does it behave it becomes
negative all right you can probably
imagine what I'm going to put on the
next row right because it's only one
other alternative versus all positive so
positive both negative positive negative
what's the other option
negative so if I start below ground and
I stop right I'm just gonna have the
same picture but in Reverse right some
finite number of terms will be negative
and at some point I know about sea level
and I stay there forever okay so I'm
going to do the reverse right you start
negative and then I'm going to now
here's where it starts to get
interesting okay because now we're
getting at the heart of why I can't ask
that question that I asked with a PS
can't ask her with GPS okay
or at least I can't in a meaningful way
let's start off in the same kind of
situation okay the simplest thing is if
you've got first time in a GP that's
positive and if your common ratio is
also positive all right now therefore
yeah
for instance this time that I ain't
started GP that I gave you before has a
positive first term in a positive ratio
and you can see this thing is just going
to climb and it's going to climb forever
it's just like scenario one so we've got
this happen
okay everything all terms in my GP will
be positive they see how its behaving
now it's important that you see even if
you've got like a really small number in
here but this is a GP that's growing do
you see that but I could just as easily
have a GP that's shrinking what kind of
value for our what I want if I want to
achieve me that's drinking less than
zero
I want one that's less than one because
if I have a value less than well let's
say okay then I'm gonna have three three
of two one 1/2 3/4 3/8 3/16 it's getting
smaller smaller smaller but in terms of
sign it's still behaving just like this
ok now the reason that I hope will
become clear in a second right instead
of going through this case I'm going to
start a different case next I'm gonna
Majan if I start negative and if my
common ratio is still positive ok think
with me think think big what if I change
the first term in this situation here I
changed the first person negative 3 what
would the next terms then there'd be
negative 3 then negative 6 then negative
12 then negative 24 do you agree with
that so what's my picture gonna look
like it'll be the whole thing we black
okay now here's the fun and hottest
picture to do I love this case and the
reason why I only have one row rather
than two rows at the bottom here it's
not an accident is that if I now make
the common ratio negative as it turns
out it doesn't really matter for our
intents and purposes it doesn't matter
whether you start with a positive or
negative and more or less the same thing
will happen let's just imagine here
let's leave a is three but let's make a
negative a equals negative two let's
just try that how would this sequence be
different and the answer is the first
term will still be three the second term
will not be six then you'll meet - it
all happened to the second term it's
still 12
why is it still 12 why is it change when
I get to the second term I'm squaring
right so the negative to the negative
will get lost right in fact for this
this term and a R to the 4 and out of
the six and all of those even powers the
negatives will disappear but for all
these odd powers you'll get that
negative right
what will the 11th term be will it be
positive or negative the 11th term will
be positive the reason you can know
there's two ways you can appeal to the
pattern right have a look at the pattern
which turns positive first and third and
seventh and ninth and eleventh all the
odd terms will be positive the other
ways you could appeal to the formula you
can say well it's a R to the N minus 1
and n is 11 so that means the power will
still be even right even though here
I've got two if minus 2 to the power 10
is still the same number so now because
I've got this flip-flopping nature what
is my diagram look like
yeah okay so in my particular example
I'm going to start like this actually
I'm gonna draw it like this okay right
so what's going on here right I noted
that strictly speaking I would have a
different version if I changed my first
term if my first term when they give
instead of going green black green black
green black it would just go black green
black green green okay but essentially
I've gone remember I'm try think about
behavior behavior I've got the same kind
of behavior this is called alternating
does this look familiar does the word
seem familiar we have to be alternating
harmonic series yesterday right well
this is an alternating GP and plenty of
gp's are alternating all you need is
this condition down yet
now can you see why I couldn't ask you
that question right when does the first
become negative right
well it'll either be the only way to get
a first negative term right is you're
either all negative in which case why I
asked the question or it's the first or
second term those are the only possible
answers right you don't get this kind of
behavior like you have with an AP
because a peach and GPS despite having
so many things in common this one when a
difference makes them behave drastically
different okay